foreign
Debra is with us in Los Angeles hi
Deborah welcome to the Ramsey Show
hey thanks so much I've been listening
to you guys for years and appreciate all
you do well thank you I have you're very
welcome
um I have a question for you I've been
listening for a long time and yesterday
I went into
um to adjust my own Investments because
I am we've been focused on other things
I wanted to get everything set up in the
four different types of mutual funds you
mentioned and the guy who is not a not a
Ramsey uh Certified Financial Pro but he
um he mentioned a term that I'd never
heard before when I brought up mutual
funds he asked me if I'd considered ETFs
and I have no idea or I hadn't heard
what that was he explained it to me and
it sounds very similar to mutual friend
so I was just wondering if you could
clarify what the difference is and why a
mutual fund is better than an ETF
I don't know that a mutual fund is
better than ATF ETF just means extreme
exchange traded fund and for purposes
you would use it for uh they're very
very similar they're almost identical uh
it's a group of
you know a group of stocks and if you're
buying an exchange you know typically
what people will do for an ETF is
something like an index fund like an S P
500 and so it'd just be a group of
stocks in there now sometimes
uh Brokers will try to get you to buy
and sell in your portfolio a lot and
they like an exchange traded fund for
that better
um and so if you're setting it up to do
like you'd set up a brokerage account to
buy and sell stocks in I would not use
it for that but if you're using it like
a mutual fund just to buy and hold
you're going to find it's almost
identical that you didn't really you're
not going to notice any difference in
the Practical use of it
so uh sometimes I hear things like well
Dave Ramsey's against ETFs I'm not
against ctfs I don't mind what I want
you to have is a diversified portfolio
mutual funds ETF is either one of those
give it to you what I don't want you to
do with an ETF is start buying and
selling all the time and I don't want
you to use any vehicle of investing that
that prompts you to constantly be
jumping in and out jumping in and out
jumping in and out because every time
the the
you know the the news is good by the
time the news is good on the stock
market you're late
you should have already been in by the
time the news is bad it's already too
late for you to get out and so people
that try to jump in and out based on the
news and you're not saying that Deborah
I'm just saying but in general if you're
trying to use an ETF to time the market
we call it then then that use is not
something that you know that we would
tell people to do ever because I don't
time the market I just buy and hold
I never sell it let's buy and keep it
and uh and well the stock market went
down yeah I know stock market went up
yeah I know
and if I just sit there uh then I'm fine
and so but but for your purposes Deborah
I think he's fine as long as you're
going to stick with it and as long as
he's not your your planner is not
recommending the ETF for purposes of
timing the market or buying and selling
or constantly trading on your funds I
don't be trading on my funds all the
time I buy them and hold them the only
time I sell a fund
is if uh it's just completely
underperformance category over a long
period of time and I don't remember the
last time I sold one it's been a long
long time because I just I play long
ball all the time play long ball I'm
always thinking what's this going to be
10 years from now what's it going to be
20 years from now not 10 days from now
not 10 months from now the emotions
don't drive it and again Deborah you're
not being accused of any of that but I'm
trying to couch my ETF answer here so I
don't get misunderstood again because
I'm not anti-etf I'm anti-timing and and
I'm anti-constantly trading because it's
effectively gambling if you try to play
the market you can really get no longer
investing you're speculating that's
correct yep and and you are you know
from a statistical standpoint not a
spiritual standpoint you are gambling
right you know and so uh and sometimes I
hear people say in the CR in the
Christian world that I'm in you know
they'll say stuff like well all all
stock market is is gambling and you
shouldn't be doing that well you don't
understand what gambling is
gambling is not based on gambling is
based on a it's a game of chance
meaning you don't have any control or
any insight that's right over the over
the output that's right investing as you
buy a piece of real estate why because
real estate's always gone up and real
estate in that neighborhood it's a great
neighborhood it's got nice trees and
it's going to be good and whatever you
know and or if you're in Arizona nice
cactuses or what I mean whatever it is
right and so you know we're gonna but we
have actual outputs that we're measuring
and and we can look at the probabilities
and it's not just a deck of cards
it's not a slot machine there's a
complete difference and there's a
difference in the spirit by which you go
at those things so none of that has to
do with Deborah but
but Deborah thanks for the question